hallo herzlich willkommen zurück weil
kari und janas antworten
wir sind halt im wunderschönen breslau
auch genannt was in deiner heimat bei
drei tagen sind wir hier auf tour und
wir besuchen ihr schulen und treffen
leute heute abend treffen zum beispiel
menschen bei einem stammtisch ist dieser
umstand dass hier in breslau janesch wie
ist es für dich zurück in deine heimat
zu sein
es ist toll meine heimat ist sehr ich
sollte mich weil meine heimat war
wirklich diese kommunistisches kaputt
ist lang und sich sehr sehr anders aus
so unerfreulich wir gehen gleich sein
musikgeschäft und da gibt es viele viele
sachen die ich gerne unsere erste frage
dies kam es jetzt vor während er zum
musiker verstehen aber planlos und dann
schreibt er dass erhalt und sehr viel
deutsch gelernt hat aber halt nicht
locke carey brief des heimatlands lerner
begriffe den etat battle to understand
varianten basic wohl beim essen passt
bisher leider nur feine dollinger watch
videos after you be there is something
they can help you can fly to germany
fortschritte
das natürlich schlecht das beste was am
meisten hilft natürlich ist es in
deutschland zu sein ist genauso bei mir
mit meinem freundes ich bin sehr unter
definiert welche holen wir lernen ich
ganz ganz schnell ganz viel und wenn ich
zu hause nehme schweren lang war
jannis kann es bestätigen also was du
tun kann ist also diese ganzen apple
schon mal gut
wir haben übrigens mittlerweile auch
eine sie denn in meinem ressort von
david of london
da mal rein und wir haben natürlich
jetzt auch unsere exercises unsere
übungsleiter das heißt zu jedem video
was wir machen kannst du ein übungsplatz
bekommen weit hetzen du kannst einfach
mitglied bei uns werden ab 1 dollar pro
video und dann bekommst du die ganzen
übungsblätter und damit kann sie
natürlich schon mal dein vokabular
vertiefen nichtsdestotrotz du solltest
mit menschen sprechen das wichtigste
wenn du nicht selber nach deutschland
kommen kann
solltest du dir vielleicht einen tandem
partner suchen entweder in deiner stadt
oder vielleicht auch über skype dass es
etwas sehr populäre die hat auch etwas
für ihn fest und sah man gibt mir
geglaubt
schreib stell dir vor du mit jemandem
wie sich mit jemanden und schreibt das
auf entweder auf deutschland trifft
kannst oder dort voll module nicht weiß
wie es weitergeht auch auf englisch und
wir übersetzen es für dich ins deutsche
und sprechen es für dich auch laut vor
und dann muss das nun lernen aber das
was du lernst ist ja nicht anders als
das was du tatsächlich gerne sagen werde
viel versprochen aber ich habe
tatsächlich auszukommen hat sich fonds
insgesamt habe ich hab mir einfach so
dialoge ausgedacht in meinem kopf und
sie dann selber gesprochen und dann auch
gut per video versetzt werden auch ich
habe das für spanisch gemacht hat -
vorgestellt eine eine senior ida sagt
auch jahresgespräch zum wurde
beschleunigt auch wenn ich gern früh
lernt man unbedingt frage weitergeht es
gibt neue fragen gerne welche gefunden
sind die häufigkeit
du hast mir die juristische geschickt
und dann nach rechts
so jetzt gefragt haben wir die nächsten
fragen rennställen sehr hilfsbereit
hospira bier kommt auch mal zurück diese
haben wir die erste episode mit lisa
gepostet lisa s zurück bei easy wärmen
viele leute gefreut und sie
wiedererkannt und er direkt vorher ist
lisa immer zur mit pia aufgetreten lisa
wir sind auch immer noch sehr große
freunde mafia macht mittlerweile eine
ausbildung zur krankenschwester
ja aber nicht wir ist in münster und
hatte leider keine zeit letztes mal
mitbekommen als dieser bei uns was sehr
schade ist und wir werden diese aber
gewalt gemeinsam wieder treffen hier
gibt es auch noch
sie war allerdings nicht hinter der
kamera wie von einigen vermutet
okay wir beide so süß ich habe viel
gelacht
der lächelt nach diesem wunderbaren
video eine frage für euch was sind eure
lieblings deutsche bücher oder einfach
ein buch auf deutsch das er empfiehlt
vielen dank sehr gute frage weil ich
lebte er kaum zählen ganz schlechter
leser und ich schlafe nur einmal lesen
und die angst immer witze über mich
allianz schließt dafür umso mehr nämlich
so ungefähr zehn bücher pro woche ja mit
was empfiehlst du ich lese allerdings
schon lange keine literatur mehr aber
ein wo es gibt es gibt mehrere bischöfe
[Musik]
empfehlen kann und zuerst vielleicht das
parfum von süsskind und das wo es
einfach unglaublich es ist unglaublich
wie der stand richtig wie die sätze
gebaut wird wie lachen
30 nicht kompliziert es ist ein
spannendes buch ein unglaubliches buch
es geht um einen menschen der die welt
welt viel mehr vom geruch her empfindet
als vom sehen und alles was sie kalt
wird von diesem geruch her beschrieben
und etwas unglaubliches tat filmte
also weg von ganztagsklassen
kindergeschichten von peter bichsel
schweiz schreibt aber auch deutschland
und diese kinder geschichten sind aber
geschichten gar nicht für kinder sondern
für erwachsene
ich hab gleich als ich einige davon
gelesen habe
also mein kaffee einfach das zu lesen
was dich persönlich interessiert also
das was du in deiner muttersprache auch
liebt und gerade ist es vielleicht auch
gar nicht schlecht so ein lieblingsbuch
oder flächen buch über ein ähnliches
thema noch mal in einer anderen sprache
zu lesen weil dann weißt du schon ein
bisschen berühmt wie zum beispiel ich
lerne polnisch am besten dadurch dass
ich songs zu hören wie er auf polnisch
friebe toll die meisten geschichten
kenne ich schon
und deswegen habe ich eine ahnung davon
was er sagt und ich war trotzdem zu und
versuche waren die strukturen zu
verstehen und verstehe schon ein paar
vokabeln und das ist einfach für mich
super interessant ich lese übrigens sehr
gerne biografien wenn ich dann lese und
ich mag überhaupt gar keine ausgedachte
sofort weitergeht möchte ich nach dieser
schönen konter vorstellen dass es hier
auch
nach links das ist für die arena hat
keine ahnung von der kunde die vielen
der mal hast du die geschichte der kunst
gelesen qualität ich kann sagen dass ich
mit kunstwerk was nacht bringt das soll
quasi gefrorenes eis darstellt sowie
verständlichere gruppe verantworten
das ist doch einfach komisch oder
es ist eine glasscheibe mit denen man
das denn der richter kennen ich finde
sehr pragmatisch und praktisch stadt
viel wasser zu verschwenden macht man
halt ein wasserfall wo die scheiben in
das wasser im mit ihr ok zu teuer
monika mal fragt alles gute im neuen
jahr ich hätte eine frage an jahr luft
und fach
hast du am anfang bei brennbaren werben
präfix nicht vergessen
ich mache auf den folgenden fehler es
sieht zb schön stadt schön auf bei
längerem setzen vergesse ich das
ausschließen
obwohl ich genau weiß dass es da sein
sollte da sein sollte er
falls du auch so einen fehler gemacht
hat es wie lange hat es gedauert bis ich
nicht mehr vergessen wird
bild gestern tatsächlich immer noch
man vergisst und ich sag dir die einzige
methode oder die beste methode um das
für überwinden ist wir muss einfach
verstehen dass das wort aussehen nicht
sehen ist und den aussehen aussehen
aussehen also wie siehst du aus bis auf
musst du kommen sonst ist das ein
falsches wort dessen habe ich gesagt ihr
fliegt ich meinte aber ihr fliegt raus
raus fliegen ist etwas ganz anderes
das muss man irgendwo in den kopf rein
bekommen ist gestern in einem video was
ihr auf den zwei wochen hat er einen
deutschen lehrer gespielt und hat
ständig selber fehler gemacht die mir
nie ausfallen
außer wenn ich darauf achte es geht
weiter
nächste frage filipov die sagt ich wohne
in rzeszów und lade euch recht herzlich
an
das ist nur eine stunde weiteren tag auf
was noch wichtig ist es gibt einen
direkten flugverbindung zwischen berlin
und löschen
danke für die einladung wir haben sind
ja gerade auf polen tour und wir wollen
euch auch einladen und zu treffen
wir haben tatsächlich einige stammten
geplant heute abend in breslau treffen
und wir passen uns morgen abend in
katowice und am nächste woche samstag
die nächste woche samstag in krakow
verkauf kommt vor wald genau ich würde
sagen die sache samstag kommt findet
nach krakau ist es ja nur eine stunde
weit weg wie du weißt du und ich sagen
wie man daher wäre es nicht cool
wo können wir abdecken wo wir genau bei
facebook facebook.com friesi german
videos dort findest du alle
informationen und dort findet ihr immer
alle termine wo wir uns treffen jetzt in
polen und bald auch wieder in berlin
die sonne geht unter mensch haben damit
schon lange unterwegs bin auch schon
ungefähr 100 meter weit gekriegt wissen
ganz hatte noch eine frage ja victoria
morena fragt gar nicht geboren waren
alle nickten und sind über volkskirche
jetzt im quartier pferd wohl nicht immer
motiviert für sachsen
alle die jetzt erfolgte mambazo dose
motivation wie du jetzt hole ich nehme
alles mit mm breit und dort lerne ich
auch ganz schnell viele neue vokabel und
wiederholen sie auch ständig und so
lerne ich freue mich und natürlich durch
zuhören und übrigens ich habe eben schon
gesagt aber danke danke danke an david
aus london
er hat aus unseren vokabeln müssten von
den episoden einen bereits kurz gemacht
und ihr könnt mal auf mehr weil dort
kaum gehen und dort nach ihnen suchen
dann könnt ihr mit den vokabeln
unseren episoden deutschland machen
danke david hallo david und vielen dank
das ist wirklich eine ganz ganz tolle
unterstützung und sinnvolle idee besten
seither lastet hallo ich wohne in
breslau und lade euch herzlich ein meine
stadt zu besuchen dahin wieder zum
verkorksten gerade in breslau wo wir
sind hier wie vor dem rathaus ratsch
hier siehst du den tannenbaum der immer
noch steht im schloss am zweiten februar
abgebaut für eine katholische tradition
in deutschland wir werden die gassen
fünften januar aus dem fenster geworfen
was wir witzig finden sind bereits laut
angedacht uns ein gerade hat jetzt muss
er auch treffen nämlich heute abend
termin und ort steht bei facebook hast
du noch eine letzte frage ist warum soll
man in deutschland eigentlich das ändern
und besetzen den 60 jahre alt der
eiserne vorhang war nicht nur eine ganze
das hat europa geteilt etwa auch ein
vorhang in meinem geist für einen großen
teil meines lebens hat in austin das
freundin war der feind gewesen und ich
habe nach dem süden und westen angesehen
ich habe in letzter zeit angefangen
wieder deutsch zu lernen alles von der
schule habe ich vergessen es hat mein
geist geöffnet und ich glaube in diesen
zeiten ist dass immer mehr
wichtiger sei jetzt auch dass ein
superschöner abschluss wort von drei
episoden und wie du siehst es ist ja
auch das ist in europa so früher war
erholen der osten von europa und sogar
getrennt und heute ist polen eigentlich
die mitte europas und wir können hin und
herreisen unterschiedlichen ländern
arbeiten und wir freuen uns sehr über
deinen kommentar dem wir einfach mal so
vorgelesen haben es gibt tausend gründe
und deutsch zu lernen aber auf jeden
fall ist der zusammenhalt in europa und
die freundschaft ein wichtiger grund
dafür
und du hast auch schon ein thema
angesprochen dass ihr diesen sonntag
lädt bei
sie können nämlich waren wir auf einer
konferenz und da ging es um die zukunft
europas und um das zusammenleben euro
passt und wir haben einige leute
interviewt unter anderem auch sehr
bekannte politiker wie frank walter
steinmeier den deutschen außenminister
und was passiert zu europa sagen das
seht ihr am sonntag der isar germany in
der zwischenzeit hat ja mich warm
eingepackt ich werde das jetzt auch bald
in brüssel zusammen kalt empfohlen
und wir gehen jetzt in einem
musikgeschäft und wir hoffen euch noch
auf dieser tour zu sehen
bitte cook & co bei facebook wo wir sind
und treffen
[Musik]
ganz erfreulich